confrontées à la crise du coronavirus la
société réunionnaise est en pleine
mutation
pour répondre à l'urgence économique
social et environnemental le département
s'engage au plus près des réunionnais et
présente son budget primitif pour
l'année 2000 21
[Musique]
un budget qui s'élève à 1 milliard 159
millions huit cent vingt-six mille euros
le budget 2021 est en augmentation de
plus de 63 millions d'euros comparé à
2020 une progression rendue possible
grâce à la recentralisation du rsa au
1er janvier 2020 et au faible niveau
d'endettement de la collectivité
malgré un contexte financier difficile
et incertain marqué par la crise du
coronavirus ses marges de manoeuvre vont
permettre une croissance
d'investissement qui atteint les 182
millions d'euros un budget qui ne
prévoit aucune hausse de la fiscalité et
qui engage les actions départementales
au plus près des réunionnais
[Musique]
le soutien à l'autonomie à tous les âges
de la vie est un poste majeur dans
l'accompagnement des publics fragiles ce
dispositif qui ont principalement en
charge les allocations individuelles de
solidarité et les dispositifs
d'inclusion sociale pour nos gramounes
comme les shaks santé les aides
ménagères pour les personnes âgées et le
transport des personnes à mobilité
réduite
suite aux appels à projets lancé la
création d'établissements médico-sociaux
permettront d'augmenter le nombre de
places ouvertes et de lutter contre la
problématique des pensions marron 82,3
millions d'euros sont engagés au budget
primitif pour soutenir l'insertion
l'emploi le logement et la coopération
le département s'engage à construire des
parcours de formation et d'insertion en
faveur des bénéficiaires du rsa des
crédits soutiendront également
l'insertion par le secteur non marchand
dans l'activité économique et par le
secteur marchand 3000 ménages en
situation de fragilité de précarité
seront accompagnés par le dispositif de
l'amélioration de l'habitat
[Musique]
au coeur des compétences de la
collectivité la protection de l'enfance
et de la famille sera soutenue avec un
budget de 125 millions d'euros
la priorité sera accordée à la
prévention des ruptures familiales avec
le financement des maisons d'enfants à
caractère social et les services
d'action éducative en milieu ouvert
des mesures d'accompagnement sociales
seront renforcées dans le cadre du plan
de lutte contre la pauvreté et de la
protection de l'enfance l'accompagnement
à la parentalité et le suivi médical des
enfants de moins de 6 ans sera également
renforcée au sein des centres de
protection maternelle et infantile
une autre action essentielle délégué au
département et la protection et la
garantie de prise en charge des mineurs
confiés à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
avec les foyers et les assistants
familiaux
les crédits dédiés à la promotion de la
culture des sports s'élève à près de 12
millions d'euros un budget en faveur du
rayonnement du monde artistique des
manifestations culturelles et du soutien
la pratique sportive des crédits
d'investissement seront également
consacrés à la restauration et à la
valorisation du patrimoine départemental
pour privilégier l'accueil des visiteurs
maintenir des perspectives d'avenir pour
notre jeunesse est essentiel et les
crédits dédiés à leur épanouissement
s'élève à 61 millions d'euros ce
financement est nécessaire au
fonctionnement et à l'équipement des 86
collèges de l'île et des soixante mille
collégiens réunionnais et crédits sont
renforcés pour accompagner les étudiants
en formation initiale à la réunion et en
mobilité
plus de deux millions d'euros seront
investis dans le programme insertion
socioprofessionnelle des jeunes
le développement de l'agriculture et de
l'eau relève du nouveau modèle de
production agricole inscrit dans le plan
agréé pays 2030 44,7 millions d'euros y
seront consacrés les orientations visite
à soutenir les filières locales à
diversifier les productions et à
favoriser l'utilisation des produits
locaux sein des restaurations
collectives
l'extension des périmètres irrigués la
structuration des équipements
hydrauliques et le contrôle sanitaire
des eaux sont également financés à
hauteur de 26 millions d'euros
[Musique]
59 5 millions d'euros sont consacrés aux
routes et à l'aménagement de l'espace
public
30 millions d'euros seront investis pour
entretenir et sécuriser les 722 km de
routes départementales des projets
d'aménagement du territoire seront
également portés au plus près des
communes avec la seconde génération des
pacte de solidarité territoriale
[Musique]
les crédits pour l'environnement le
tourisme et l'aménagement des eaux
s'élève à 33,2 millions d'euros des
engagements qui vise à la protection et
à l'aménagement des espaces naturels et
forestier 800 hectares seront valorisés
et 150000 plantation d'espèces
endémiques seront réalisés dans le cadre
du plan un million d'arbres 2021 verra
également la mise en oeuvre du plan de
transition écologique et solidaire avec
notamment le développement des énergies
propres
la mise en place d'ateliers déco
exemplarité et la protection de
l'environnement une politique publique
qui construit la réunion de demain et
qui apporte des solutions face aux
enjeux climatiques
le budget 2021 prend également en compte
l'amélioration de l'aménagement et le
développement écotouristique du
territoire avec pour objectif
d'augmenter de 10% la fréquentation des
équipements et du patrimoine de la
collectivité
les travaux de construction du nouveau
gîte du volcan seront lancés en 2021
[Musique]
des dépenses d'administration générale
du département sont en évolution
maîtrisée de 1% avec une logique de
continuité de la modernisation
territoriale d'amélioration des
conditions de travail de développement
durable et d'une gestion efficace des
dépenses avec son budget primitif pour
l'année 2000 21 le département
confortent ces dispositifs et innove
dans l'accompagnement des publics
vulnérables
la collectivité ambitionne un retour
vers la croissance économique
un accompagnement social renforcé et une
transition écologique qui se veut
solidaire une politique publique
départementale qui place l'humain au
coeur de tous ces dispositifs
[Musique]